face the nation moderator John Dickerson
is with us he is also the new chief
Washington correspondent for CBS News
congratulation to let me begin with
Michael Flynn how do we assess this does
he have what might he tell the
committees or anyone else that might be
damning to the president well the first
question is what does it mean for him to
be asking for protection I think it
could be just a lawyer doing his job
right just to say in this political
environment everybody wants to know what
Michael Flynn knows and everybody is
claiming particularly in this highly
partisan environment that he did this
that and the other thing so if you're
the lawyer you want him protected
whether he's got a good story to tell or
not so so that's the first thing to keep
in mind but he's the central guy to ask
he was the president's top foreign
policy adviser so he's at the center of
Russia but then also to all the other
decisions the president or then
candidate Trump all the other things he
thought about foreign policy he was
right in the center at his elbow he
would know a lot and he didn't seem to
be having a lots of conversations with
lots of people that's right and we still
don't know this central question is when
he was talking to the Russians before
the election talking to the Russian
ambassador before the election and then
after the election on this key period of
Russian sanctions when the Obama
administration was thinking of putting
sanctions on the Russians for meddling
in the election Michael Flynn was also
talking to the Russian ambassador how
much was he telling Donald Trump about
that was he sent at President or
then-candidate Trump's behest
what was the back-and-forth what did
Donald Trump know that is still an open
question Michael Flynn is the person
you'd want to ask the president has just
tweeted this John that that he should
ask for immunity because this is a witch
hunt well there you go I mean so that's
both framing because the president wants
this to look like not a sign of guilt
the way the president right I mean it
wasn't just Michael Flynn who framed
quite request for immunity as guilt the
president when he was a candidate did
that as well so he's trying to change
the framing of the story but again a
good lawyer would ask for immunity even
if Michael does he get immunity
it hasn't been granted yet no apparently
it has not been granted yet and then
that's the question I mean part of
what's happening here is the lawyer
working on Michael Flynn's behalf trying
to get the best deal for his client
possible but they may not want to give
immunity for a variety of other reasons
but now we have yet another storyline in
this story that keeps producing more
story let's talk about Devin
so it's now been revealed that his
sources were two officials from the
White House it's interesting because in
the beginning he said he had to get to
the White House to tell the president
because his staff was not aware and the
president wasn't aware that seems to
there two problems very opposite of what
is happening there two challenges for
the chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee one is is he working was he
working with the White House to get the
White House information out while at the
same time investigating those same
people in the White House and remember
the underlying thing that he's worried
about is a very serious charge and we
shouldn't lose track of that which is
that the allegation is that some people
who were captured in surveillance had
their names unmasked and that would be a
big deal if it were true but that's been
sort of this other story is coming here
so there's the one question is he
working with the White House that he's
supposed to be investigating the second
is his credibility because he was saying
I'm rushing to give them information
that we now know he may have gotten from
in the White House in which case he was
just taking calls - another question is
who unmasked those names well that's the
question there is a formal process as I
understand for unmasking the names and
the chairman Nunez has said he'll get
that information it was supposed to come
last week now we're supposed to come
this week this should be knowable in
other words there are forms that have to
be filled out to unmask people and then
the question is were they unmasked for
legitimate reasons you can unmask the
position of a man standing has to come
from pretty high up to get him unmasked
it does now there is also somebody I was
talking to was saying yes it has to come
from high up but you can have kind of
other people do it for you so it may
take a little digging to find out who
asked for the unmasking was it
legitimate and then what was done with
that was it put in lots of reports so
that it could be leaked how is it
handled I mean in that serious business
and this was within the Obama
administration well that's the
allegation well can we just say again
congratulations when I asked Ryan
caetera what does this new title mean
chief Washington correspondent as Bob
Schieffer is old title means that you
are now the chief honcho and all we know
who called in Washington
congratulations thank you thanks